Đến sáng 1828, tổng số nạn nhân được tình kiếm kêu nạn kêu hộ là bụng bi bệnh người.
Trong đó có mùi người được kêu sống, ba mì bệnh người.
Họng số này có bụng nạn nhân đang thích tục đực sốc miền dành tính.
Chính sịch kêu hộ được triệu phai khẩn chương, vui động gần 8,000 người tự các lực lượng quân độ,
công an, cạnh sát biến, biến phòng, đặc con nước và ngưu dân địa phương.
Bốn tạo cầu đã kéo con tạo biến nạn lên khỏi mất nước và lúc 2 giờ sáng 208,000 người
hỗ trợ việc tình kiếm các nạn nhân.
Trong số người xong sốt có một mẹ trái mì bốn tội được xảy kêu sau hơn bốn dự mắc kẻ trong khoảng kính.
Mình người bị thương đang được được gì tại mình vĩnh đa khoảng ninh và bình vĩnh bại trái.
Thủ tướng triệu phủ đã ban hành công định một trong mì bốn yêu cầu hình chương kêu nạn khắc phục hộ quà.
Phó thủ tướng trên thông hà chức tiếp chỉ đạo tại hiện chường.
Tình khoảng ninh khỗ trợ 2,5% mộ người tự vong và 3% mộ người bị thương.
Kính công tác tình kiếm phấn đăng được đẩy nhanh trước khi báo số ba, huy pha, anh rường tới khu vực.